hello everyone and welcome to the other
decisive game from round eight of this
year's Tata still Masters Edition it is
Yan pishi versus notbe Abdu satov and
it's a really really wild game nrec just
had a brilliant victory in the previous
round uh he defeated Anish giri last
year's winner and now he faces one of
the candidates of the F candidates
tournament Yanni pishi so let's see what
happened here it's a really nice game I
sure you guys will enjoy it he goes Pawn
to E4 nepo uh we have Pawn to E5 by
Notre backck Knight to F3 Knight to C6
and now Bishop to C4 the Italian game is
on the board we have Knight F6 the two
knights defense and now not everyone's
favorite Knight G5 but rather D3 the the
modern Bishop's opening the slow
approach with have Bishop D7 and Castles
by both players with have Rook D1 and
pawn to D6 so the main line nothing new
happening here and pawn to A4 uh which
is usually met with um Knight to A5 and
it's a similar idea that you will find
in for example even in the real Lopez
where you want to advance the C uh the C
Pawn all the way to C5 to control the
center and then you will figure out what
what happens with Knight probably you
just bring it back uh or you go Bishop
to E6 which is what NRE does and Yan
just goes Pawn to A5 usually Knight beat
the D2 Spate here A5 is already a fairly
rare idea and not just plays B captures
and C4 now interestingly Daniel dubo had
this position three times with the black
pieces and in all three games danil went
Pawn to A6 but dubov goes Bishop
captures and C4 he ruins Neo's Pawn
structure and now D captures and C4 and
yes you do have a double C Pawn but you
do have nice control over the center and
later on you will be able to give up
that pawn with a pawn push like C5 uh
and if not you will still just have the
control of the center so it's a pretty
uh fine position we have Pawn to B6 and
now just Bishop to D2 where Norbeck
needs to make a decision does he want to
capture A5 or does he want to leave the
pawn there where nippa will have some
future option of going a captur some B6
or maybe even uh going uh full full
forward with Pawn to A6 and sort of
cramping the position so notb does trade
Knight captures we have Bishop captures
and A5 B captures and Rook captures we
have Pawn to C6 now putting pressure on
the rook and uh maybe even preparing D5
and nepo goes back with Rook to A2 now
uh if you had this position Rook to A6
looks like a really nice move you know
you keep the tension you keep an active
Rook you put pressure on the C6 Pawn but
Rook to A2 is the top move recommended
by the engine and uh yeah I imagine
nippo has everything still prepared as
he spent literally no time getting to
this position uh and um uh now uh it is
now of course as of move 13 that we have
a completely new game there is a game
that was played in 1997 where Pawn to B4
was played and although I I always say
that pawn to B4 is the strongest move
here is it's one of those positions
where it's really not it gets nicely
countered by Pawn to D5 which was missed
in the game from 1997 but okay Rook to
A2 by nepo and now uh Queen to C7
continuing development connecting Rooks
we have Knight to C3 and now Pawn to A5
stopping any B4 ideas that notbe might
have so Queen to E2 and now Knight to D7
the Knight can be REM maneuvered to B6
to put pressure on C4 also to maybe help
the pawn Advance even further uh plus
you have support for F5 or F6 if needed
uh so Pawn to B3 by nepo and Knight to
C5 the Knight is excellently placed here
there is no D Pawn to kick it away and
B4 of course cannot be played so here
Knight to A4 offering a trade of knights
but um doing so would only help nepo if
Notre Beck traded here then nepo has a
clear Rook E1 goes after the A5 Pawn you
can put more pressure uh you get the
Knight into the game uh so it's going to
going to be very very hard to defend
that pawn so instead Knight back to E6
by Notre back now eyeing that D4 square
and now nepo plays Pawn to C5 what we've
discussed yes he does have a double Pawn
a double C Pawn but he can always just
give it away and uh what can notbe play
well he could just ignore it play
something like Rook a to d8 or Rook F to
d8 but he actually captures the pawn D
captures and C5 so now he's up a pawn uh
but his beautiful Central Pawn structure
is ruined we have Knight back to B2 now
as there is no more uh possibility of D5
Neo's Knight is coming to C4 from where
it will attack the weak A5 pawn and the
weak E5 Pawn so how can Notre play this
well okay Knight to D4 you would very
much enjoy if nepo just traded here and
you could UND double your pawns uh but
uh he just moves the queen queen to D3
and now we have Queen to B8 uh
interestingly Rook F to d8 doesn't
really do all that much there are no
useful discoveries with the Knight
whatever you capture the White Queen is
the defending that so the White Queen
can just capture it back so Queen to B8
first um uh preparing to bring the queen
all the way to B4 and now Notre needs to
figure out how to defend this position
A5 will be under attack and also E5 will
be under attack once Knight to C4 lands
uh so first Rook a to E1 attacking the
pawn and now Rook to d8 uh trying to
trying to give up the A5 Pawn for some
nasty discoveries and here if you
capture on A5 then Knight captures on F3
comes with check if Queen captures Rook
captures on A5 and after Rook captures
maybe this queen to B4 could be a little
bit annoying coming to D2 putting
pressure on C2 once the The Rook returns
so there's no need for nepo to rush
anything after this um Rook to d8 move n
would just played Pawn to G3 uh getting
rid of any back rank issues that he
might have Queen to B4 and now only now
Knight to C4 and now you have a problem
your A5 is attacked and your E5 is
attacked uh how do you play this well
best would be to play F6 give up the A5
pawn and you know hope hope for the best
but Notre backck tried to solve this
tactically he played Knight to B5 with
the idea of Queen to C3 and now nepo
just moves the queen as the queen is
under attack Queen to E3 and now Queen
to C3 just Knight F captures on E5 also
putting pressure on that C6 Pawn but
okay Norbeck will eliminate the E4 Pawn
uh Rook 8 to C8 defending the C6 pawn
and now Queen captures Queen on C3
Knight captures on C3 Rook captures on
A5 and Knight captures on e4 uh the
material is equal but this is what nepo
wanted when he played that pawn to C5
move uh the Double C pawns are very very
hard to defend and the C2 Pawn which is
the base of the pawn chain and if you
want to take anything on the queen side
you have to first eliminate the C2 Pawn
it's very very hard to reach there's no
way to kick away the knight from C4 and
as long as the Knight is on C4 there is
no way you're playing Knight to D2 to so
uh here Knight to B6 attacking The Rook
Rook to C7 and now Rook to A8 not
allowing um any Rook to D2 ideas as you
would just lose tactically even a slow
move here is just dead loss for not like
he plays H6 you just capture on d8 with
check play Rook E8 and that's it there's
no way to defend the bishop so F6
attacking the Knight he has to allow the
other Rook on the back rank Rook
captures on d8 Bishop captures and Rook
to A8 putting pressure on the Bishop so
F captures on E5 it's the only thing you
have Rook captures on d8 with check and
now King to F7 and once again Knight
back to C4 and now again Notre has the
weak uh Double C pawns and the weak E
Pawn and nepo really without any
weaknesses in the position the C2 Pawn
is weak but the Rook will reach it very
hard and uh well the Knight needs a lot
of moves to to get to that pawn you
would have play something like Knight G5
Knight to E6 Knight to D4 and then
attack it but that's a lot of moves so
here first king to E6 by Norbeck King to
G2 we have Knight back to F6 and now
King to F3 and here it's very hard to
find an active plan for Norbeck best
hope for is that nepo is unable to push
this to to win maybe play G5 H5 keep
that white king at Bay but he played
Pawn to E4 with check at least getting
rid of the pawn from E5 on e4 is nicely
defended by the knight uh but uh you
allowed the white King into the game
King to F4 uh and uh now comes King to
E7 just waiting to see what nepo will do
this attacks The Rook we have Rook back
to D6 uh and now Rook to C8 maybe trying
to get all the way to the second rank
maybe to undermine those pawns Pawn to
H3 and now Knight to E8 kicking away The
Rook from this active Square uh we have
Rook back to D1 and just Knight to F6
notbe was very low on time he had some
two minutes on the clock nippo had maybe
40 minutes on the clock and two more
moves need to be made to reach time
control and it's very interesting that
nepo is the one who actually repeats
Rook D6 Knight to E8 Rook back to D2
Knight to F6 and now he goes Knight to
D6 so it's like he wanted Notre backck
to gain additional time uh in order to
to just crush him you know uh ever so
masterfully with notbe having sufficient
time on the clock he didn't just want to
allow not to say okay I lost I didn't
have enough time on the clock no NE
wants to prove that he can uh just push
this to a full point uh and here uh if
you go something like Rook to d8 which
seems like a good idea Knight F5 check
just ends the game you have to defend
your Rook uh but G7 Pawn will fall so
you play King E8 now this Pawn Falls
with check you move now Rook Falls and
after King uh goes to d8 Knight E6 check
will pick up the C5 Pawn then you will
pick up the E4 pawn and you you'll just
eliminate all of the pawns so instead
Rook to A8 by Notre backck now comes
Knight captures on e4 grabbing more
material Knight to D5 check King to E5
and now Pawn to C4 trying to ruin nepo
Pawn structure now B captures on C4 and
Knight to B6 going after the C4 Pawn but
just Rook to E2 nreb say uh nepo says
you can have that pawn so nreb captures
it with check King D4 and now Knight to
A3 putting pressure on C2 but um not
really not really a problem just Pawn to
C4 uh also the Knight does have some
discoveries but going after the dh7 pawn
would just be greedy you can always take
that there's no need to rush it uh Rook
to B8 and now we have Rook to A2 again
Knight G5 check goes after the pawn but
nepo says uh nope it's time to go after
the Knight the Knight really doesn't
have uh all that many squares this
covered by the pawn covered by the king
um C2 covered by The Rook you can go to
B1 uh but if you go Knight to B1 then
Rook to A7 check and then you just allow
King to C5 and you just get destroyed so
here Rook to A2 and now uh Rook to A8
just defending that Knight and now Rook
to B2 we have King to E6 uh King to C3
now uh we have King to E5 and now Knight
to D2 defending the C4 pawn and now it's
a question whether that Knight can
escape if you attack it with the rook
and with the King how is the Knight to
escape well uh there is a way uh Rook to
A7 is played now comes Rook to B3 uh
putting pressure on the Knight King to
E6 and now it seems like King to B2 just
traps the Knight there's no square for
the Knight but Notre backck had Rook to
D7 in mind and now you capture The Rook
the Knight Norbeck captures Neo's Knight
so there's no again no need to rush this
Knight to F1 by nepo King to D6 and now
Knight back to D2 King to E6 here uh
neppo I believe repeated he wanted to
give notbe a chance to play King to C5
in order to deliver this Knight to E4
Checkmate as C5 is in check and the D6
is covered by the Knight so it would be
funny but you never know you know people
do run in walk right into Checkmate so
of course notbe goes back King E6 Now
Pawn to H4 King to F5 and just Pawn to
F3 fully controlling that black king uh
Pawn to H6 now comes Rook to B6 putting
pressure on the C6 Pawn uh Rook to E7
and now Knight to E4 notice that uh okay
The Rook is not attacking the Knight but
there's still no way for that Knight to
get into the game this covered this is
covered this is covered uh and the B1
square is covered so it's just a you
know a useless piece uh we have Pawn to
G5 And nepo Trades once captures
captures and now eliminates the C6 Pawn
so now nepo is up two pawns and of
course you know that when you're up two
Pawns in an end game you are completely
winning unless it's one of those
positions uh Pawn to G4 trying to mess
up U the pawn structure maybe you can
you know uh for Force nepo to capture
somehow and then eliminate the two pawns
uh but just Knight to D6 with check and
now the problem is it doesn't matter
where you go if you go King to E5 or
King to G5 just a pawn to F4 with check
to give you an example Pawn to F4 check
King H5 Rook to C5 with check King G6
and now you just deliver a check and
well you can even pick up one more Pawn
or even if King to H6 check you can go
for Knight F5 check picking up the Rook
um so you know not the best so nepo goes
King to F6 it looks like it runs into a
very nasty Discovery but of course you
can always block check with the Rook so
Knight to C8 check Rook to E6 and now
Rook captures on E6 of course Napa will
go into Knight and pawn end game as the
Knight on A3 has no squares King
captures on E6 and now Pawn to F4 and he
was in this position un move 65 that NRE
abdat resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here your knight
cannot can never enter the game and uh
well since the Knight can't enter the
game it's merely a matter of pushing
pawns and you win that's that's all
there is to it uh even if something like
King F5 you will play Knight to D6 check
uh stop the king from advancing and if
King to A6 just Knight B5 you offer a
trade and now if you trade you're just
up two pawns and if you go Knight to B1
check still King C2 and you have no
squares the Knight covers A3 you just
lose uh so very interesting uh game uh
it was a just a you know positional
Masterpiece by nepo against Notre who
who just round prior to this one had his
positional Masterpiece to Anish gear
last year's winner uh notice that I did
not have a pause the video moment
because it was just uh a very very slow
squeeze it was uh you know there there
was no real mistake that ended the game
for notb it was just you know uh you
know give a little bit to your opponent
then give a little bit more then give a
little bit more and over time you know
the the the advantage is uh just uh you
know compiled and uh uh that's all there
is so there was no mistake or anything
that I could make pause the video moment
it was just uh beautifully played uh
game by nepo he prepared this um very
rare line very masterfully I don't know
maybe maybe he did discuss it with dubov
a little bit as dubov does play this
with black so maybe he asked him how how
do you approach this with white or maybe
it's just something that the you know
the Russians just know about this line
uh or you know maybe it's some leftover
from from the World Chess Championship
match that he never used you you never
know uh but yeah brilliant stuff by
neppo and since um this is the last game
we'll be showing from roundout the eight
let's check out the standings after
round eight so we have a three-way tie
Anish giri gesh and ala fuja on Five
Points in close Pursuit on four and a
half points we have Yan paganda and NRE
abdat and V Gujarati so had Notre Beck
won this he would be in sole lead with
five and a half but Neo had something to
say about that on Four Points Max feram
and we uh interestingly uh on 10 and 11
we have the two world champions juun and
ding Len uh on three points z f Forest
um uh also one of of the winners of the
of the Tata steel param makulu and
Alexander donchenko on two and a half
and the other results of the other games
if you guys are interested here we have
vitan donchenko drer game Max far and
prag drer games uh juen GES also a draw
GES was really trying to push for a win
with the extra Pawn but um was unable to
do so he undefeated notb Anish and Wei
was a draw ala defeated dlan if you
haven't seen in my previous video do
check it out really wonderful stuff by
Ala uh and Jordan and param Juda games
uh so yeah uh that's the game some
little a little bit of info about the
event very much looking forward to round
nine if you guys are interested I can
also tell you the pairings of round nine
haven't really prepared that but yeah
I'm pretty sure you guys would be
interested in that so in round nine we
will have donchenko versus ala Fu jading
will face Anish giri so a big matchup
gesh will face vidit also a big matchup
Maul will face Max fadam Abdu satro will
face Jordan van Forest we will face
Yanni pishi also a big game for Yan if
he can do something with the black
pieces there but also for way with white
and PR will Face women's world champion
J and June so again I mean all of the
games are interesting uh we we will
every round is just uh you know full
full of action full of surprises and I
can't wait for it to to to start uh so
yeah once again hope you enjoyed that I
would like to thank Johan Cen Len
Herbert Y young an anonymous person and
Christopher and Ruth brette for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check through my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day